okay uh so the last talk of today is
slightly different from the topics uh
from the previous talks uh I'm going to
talk about something uh unrealizable in
the classical World
um and the the title is long okay and
this is George work with heart and Mark
and uh the paper is uh in eurocrypt and
qip and you can check out also there are
short talks online and there's uh the
paper is posted on ePrint and archive
so we know that with Quantum information
we can do uh lots of different things
um some of these is classically
realizable but we might get it from
weaker assumptions on or it's come if
you you are allowed to send Quantum
information and some of these are uh are
quantumly a classically unrealizable
um and so and all of these are very
relevant to something called No cloning
principle
uh so the nuclear principle says they
cannot uh make copies of arbitrary or
non-quantum States
um and as I mentioned I I will focus on
uh Quantum money which is uh I think one
of the central topics in in the world of
on clonable Quantum cryptography and
this is put forward by Wister as a
pioneering idea in the 60s
uh so the uh the problem of quantum
money says that there is a a bank and it
wants to issue a banknote as a Quantum
state so that the honest user with a
copy of this banknote uh it can get
verified by the bank uh but the if a
malicious user
tries to make two copies of this
banknote so that they can both pass the
verification uh it cannot be able to do
so
and today uh the talk outline uh I will
basically focus on uh so actually there
are like three items here but uh uh so
firstly I will talk about the motivation
a brief history and I will talk about
the the main uh the two major results of
our paper uh they are sort of as Organo
so uh because of this relation to
minimizing assumptions so we'll probably
uh put more weight on the first part
um and also due to restriction of that
time I I can only focus on uh on one of
the one of them but I'm going to talk
about the second part briefly in any
ways and
okay so um so why why does Quantum money
matter uh so as I mentioned firstly it's
it's not uh realizable in the classical
crypto World unlike uh some some of
these Quantum Primitives they they can
they can be built in the classical world
but with stronger assumptions uh and but
the classical information can always be
copied so this this is simply impossible
um and it's very relevant to other
uncloneable cryptography and also uh
post Quantum proofs uh for example uh as
I will mentioned they are related to
this collapsing Notions which people use
to to show uh post Quantum security and
they are also related to there are
building blocks and also related to
something called uh copy protection or
as well as it's a weaker variants such
as copy detection or secures of
releasing actually if you you want to
build those uh Primitives in many of the
settings you have to have Quantum money
first because they would imply public
something called public key Quantum
money which I will talk about is the
stronger side of a Quantum money and
they can also be uh used as for example
chainless blockchain if we can build
something uh build one once uh one of
the those stronger notion of quantum
money called Quantum lightening which I
will go into so that would help us build
chainless blockchain
um and okay so so Quantum money uh as I
mentioned there are like actually two uh
several Barons but uh I will mostly
focus on uh
on the heart attacks and uh here is the
easier text the easier text is that uh
okay when I generate the quantum money
uh the bank the vendor uh takes in the
security parameter and the samples some
classical security key and generate that
called the money according to the secret
key
um and when the verify when the user
wants uh its state to be verified it has
to go to the bank or someone some
designated verifier that has the secret
key in order to verify this state
and indeed you can get such a primitive
easily and one of them is this conjugate
coding skin which is widely used and as
we have widely talk about in in many of
these Quantum crypto constructions is
that you just sample a random string and
a random basis and you encode the
stating in that random basis and
and there is also uh you can also get it
from through the random States uh and in
general if uh you you have your sample
classical random string and there is a
efficient UNIF uh unitary procedure to
turn it into some computationally on
chronable State uh then you can get
private key for the money just by having
this key you should be able to
uh reverse the procedure and check
whether it's the state you want
okay so so there should be many
constructions but uh the thing is uh
private key Quantum money is not
satisfying it's very limited imagine you
you hold the quantum State and you want
to do a transaction you have to go to
the bank to to verify each transaction
so what we want is is the harder goal
that's probably key Quantum money that
is uh when I generate the money state I
I generate along with a public key um
and
and what I want is that uh that a
malicious user you shouldn't be able to
generate uh too many states that get get
uh verified by both of them get verified
by the public key so everyone can access
the public key and uh including
including this malicious uh user and
this public key will contain some
auxiliary information about the quantum
state of course because uh because you
need that to verify the quantum state so
so uh so the thing is okay this probably
definitely requires some sort of
computational assumptions because uh
unbounded adversary should always be
able to just immune enumerates through
all states and using the public key to
check whether it works
and there's even a stronger variant
that's called Quantum lightening
uh I think some of the animation comes
in in a bit Disorder so in a Quantum
money scheme I said I I generate a money
state and there is like a unique
classical uh number it's called Sigma
here that specifies the uniqueness of
these banknotes I give that to the I
give that to uh adversary and it would
try to the everything will try to
generate two money states with the same
serial number that counts as a
successful attack
um and in a Quantum lightening scheme
it's a money scheme where where even a
malicious user is allowed to generate
money State uh but what it uh so so it
can generate uh but what it does uh it's
not able to do is that it cannot
generate on its own too many states with
the same serial number
so uh basically there is some trusty
Authority that public publishes a common
reference string and
others would be able to generate back
notes from this common reference string
and you can consider probably in a
decentralized model there there is some
other protocol that uh sort of gives
authentication to this background once
generated to make it a valid back note
but what it's not allowed to do is that
it is not supposed to to generate to to
money states that has the same serial
number
and I would say a slightly
inaccurate uh anal classical analog of
these two Notions that uh
in a Quantum money scheme it's like a
certain pre-image resistance and I give
you a specific money stay with this
unique serial number and I ask you to
find a segment if they correspond to
this serial number and for the quantum
line analysis I don't limit you to any
specific serial number you are just
asking ask to to find two states that
client so it's like Collision resistance
and that's why it's a stronger and
harder goal
and now we can look at a history of
struggles for public key quarter money
so there is some of those schemes which
are already broken most of them are
built from Olivia at home can now
standard assumptions and there's a few
uh schemes with checks uh that that that
are provably secure
and the most of them are either oracles
or you uh or the only one in the playing
model is uses Assumption of post Quantum
secure i o
and there's uh some other works which
are not yet broken but uh we do not know
uh much crypto analysis on there on
these constructions
um and these highlighted ones they are
these ones highlighting orange they are
quantum lightening candidates so either
there are also either oracles or uh some
some assumptions that we do not know
much crypto analysis are
and today we uh uh so first thing we
would we would show that uh this recent
work by kashin Liu and Shore uh which
try to build Quantum money more specific
they try to build Quantum lightning on
lattices uh actually does not work and
uh broad class uh of schemes that can be
extended from their construction cannot
work either
um and and we show and we in the second
part of our work we would go back to a
previous paper by these people uh farhi
uh go said hasidim the tomersky and
short uh where the uh they build Quantum
money are not and we we try to
generalize and Abstract their framework
and show that okay there's a under some
assumptions there's a framework of
quantum money schemes that's actually
quite different from most of the other
existing schemes and uh and they might
and it might be promising for for us to
build Quantum money and even Quantum
lightning from and we would thank the
authors for answering our questions
through the process uh the process of
writing the paper
um okay so so let's go into the first
part that is this attack on a specific
type of lattice based Quantum money
uh so before going to that I will
briefly go over some of the lattice
assumptions we use
um so some of you might already be
familiar with this the first is short
inter short integer Solutions assumption
that is uh given this random Matrix
uh I need to find a vector that is in in
the now space or kernel of the Matrix uh
and this is easy uh if you don't require
other restrictions just doing gaussian
elimination but the thing is I uh I now
require this Vector to have a short Norm
and then there are this sort of Ideal
problem of this uh show the interior
solutions that is called learning with
arrows where also I also give you these
random Matrix either give you a system
of linear equations they are trying to
find this uh this solution but the thing
is I also mask these linear equations
with with some small caution arrows and
that makes the problem hard
and then there's the search version of
this problem just asking you to to
distinguish this gaussian mask linear
equations from random
and okay so uh What uh so let before
going to the kashinlu short uh skin I
will just talk about uh an odor skin
which is very uh which is
um in Spirit uh what question does but
they did a variant of it and I I will
explain this proposal and why it does
not work and this is proposed informally
uh in January's uh 2019 Quantum
lightening paper
um so the idea is okay uh
now now it's a Quantum lightning scheme
and I have some public parameters where
everyone can use to generate Quantum
money States and now I I just sample a
uniform random Matrix and that's my
public parameter and to prepare a bounty
State I prepare this gaussian weighted
superposition over some short vectors uh
this can be done efficiently with
a Quantum analog of rejection sampling
in the gpv sampling algorithm if you are
familiar with their latest techniques in
any case the first step is easy the
second step is I just apply this Matrix
coherently to these uh to these vectors
and I measure the output register which
collapse the state to all short vectors
that satisfy a y equals U for some
random U I obtain from the measurement
and now this pre-image register becomes
my money state the quantum part of my
Ministry and this measurement outcome
becomes my unique serial number
okay uh this is my money state and this
is easy and this function I will call it
this has functioned some some people
couldn't I tie hash function and this is
a very uh
uh often seeing a hedge function in the
lattice literature
and why do we think this works uh let's
now give some intuition on why why uh
why Gentry believed and why cashing
believe this work because there are some
there is some magic intuition behind
this is that okay suppose I have some
powerful verification that helps me
verify this money state
uh and uh I I know that if I I get an
honest money state I measure it I would
get a random Vector that satisfy random
Vector why that satisfy a y equals U
and recorded this problem asked me to
find some short Vector uh in the kernel
of a
so if I have too many states I just
measure them
because they are discussion with his
superpositions and I would with
overwhelming probability I would just
get different short vectors and they
would all map to the same you so if I
subtract them this difference will give
me a short Vector that's in the kernel
of a and that helps me solve uh disease
problem so so you can see that the
argument there is like no Direct
uh comment about like no cloning but
this is a this is the computational
intuition on why this can't be cloned
but I will explain why this won't work
uh so the things as I uh mentioned I I
said okay let's ignore verification and
they see tuition does this intuition on
the reduction does go through but what
about uh verification so how do you
exactly verify this money state is the
caution weighted superposition of short
vectors in this coset
uh so if you just measure if you okay
you can apply a uh in the computational
basis coherently and check whether it
computes yield you can do that but that
applies to a classical Vector as well
so what I want to do is I want to take
use of these Quantum structures let me
do a qft to the state
and by the seminal work of rigaf we
would say we would magically get this uh
lwe samples if we do a qft
from discussion weighted uh
superposition of short vectors
um and okay so so so since it has put
structures in both the computational and
handmark basis maybe I can take use of
these structures and check whether it is
the state I want
so if I can have some magic LW
distinguisher checking whether these are
valid lwe samples uh then then I should
be down and I I basically I I'm saying
that if I can do this I can project down
to the state
however this is simply not doable
because distinguishing LW samples from
random is hard
and basically in previous work by Lou
and gentry it says that okay we simply
cannot tell whether these short Vector
state is measured or not
um assuming
a super polynomial modulus uh under the
assumptions of lwe some intuition uh is
that basically if you um
uh basically uh trying to distinguishing
this this superposition of LW samples uh
it's the same as trying to distinguish
an LW sample from
a uniform random value
and that that there is a very easy proof
If you just consider a gaussian weighted
state but it's more complicated if it's
a uh it's some random other random way
tested nevertheless you can show that if
you just choose a uniform random a to
prepare this state for start uh these
collapsing this property called
collapsing always holds
so now the attack is very easy
uh
so after receiving this date uh the
adversary simply make uh makes a
measurement in the computational basis
and just make two copies of it and both
of them should pass verification Because
unless the distinguisher can break lwe
shouldn't be able to tell this uh this
uh measurement outcome from a real money
state so the previous reduction does not
go through because in the previous
reduction we were assuming that the
adversal actually has to produce
different vectors but it has it doesn't
have to
okay so so the okay so the terminal by
caching to ensure is that okay uh as we
said there are some uh there are some
properties of the previous result he
said a is uniform random and uh and also
uh you know that even though uh LW is in
many cases uh
you know their search to decision
reduction but there may be weird uh
parental regime where decisional is easy
so that makes it easy for the
um distinguisher to tell but uh
still finding a short Vector is hard
and their proposal is that um so now
instead of sampling a unit for random a
i for example some short vectors and I
sample a that's orthogonal to these uh
short vectors and you will see that okay
I I and I would publish these short
vectors as the public parameters as well
and you will see that okay I now I
already have the short vectors so so
what do I do uh isn't the short integer
solution problem already solved okay the
thing is okay now I ask you to do
something different I asked you to find
a linearly independent short Vector that
that's also in a kernel so I give you
something in the kernel you have to find
me something different and that's their
intuition so using these short vectors
you can easily check under the hand Mark
basis whether they are a valid lwa
samples
um but the question comes okay so how do
we enforce the adversary to
to find uh to to produce how do they
reinforce the adversary to be produce
like a different short Vector from the
forgeries of quantum money
so yeah but the answer is actually you
you cannot
and we would be able to show that uh
even with all these modifications no
efficient and verification can exist
because you simply cannot tell a real
Quantum money from a fake money stay
prepared by a partial measurement using
these public informations and this is
based on standard lattice assumptions
so in fact this modifications they don't
inherently change the big picture so
what do uh
what you have is that uh
a real money state which is a question
with the superposition of this original
Short vectors and there is a forgery of
the money state that has the form which
is you may you get a measurement outcome
and you you add some linear combinations
of these short vectors uh and these
these two should be indistinguishable
after the qft because of a variant of
lwe
which we can obtain from standard
assumptions and I I won't go into the
details of this proof but the the the
high level intuition on these cavities
is that this verification so it it
actually accepts a much larger Subspace
than the value money state it actually
accepts the Subspace that's
Organo to to these uh these three
vectors instead of the Subspace of uh
of a perp and also it does not force the
adversary to produce new short raptures
so are you is it possible that Cyclone
can reproduce many times like how is
this
well yeah the thing is
uh these uh
so even of these short factors you can
you can do something uh like a GPB
sampling algorithm to to sample self
proportion weighted vectors culture with
the state of the foreign form so it's a
given side I can create PSI Prime in
such a way that I can produce many
copies of science yes right
Yeah so basically I I don't I I'm not
like keeping keep inside and pretending
right now that's a problem I'm like
actually measuring and measuring it and
I create that front yeah can you repeat
how you make the five times from side uh
yeah I think uh the thing is basically
uh you are uh you're trying to uh do
this GPB sampling algorithm using these
uh information about these short vectors
given out
um
and basically that's like a uh
like like upon analog of this
center with the center shifted by by the
one measurement outcome of one and
you'll be able to obtain something
that's
uh
that will be uh
they will be able to obtain like short
vectors in uh
internet is that specified by by a
Subspace that's orthogonal to the
Subspace of uh span by s y S1 S2 S3 here
I'm just giving out three
of them but in fact if there are there
are constant many of them you can you
are still able to do this efficiently
so basically yeah you need to find like
given this information you need to find
like a short basis for for this for this
fake clarities which is not the origin
that you see they want you to do but you
can you can find these fake letters
which will be able to pass the
verification because what they
essentially they verify is is whether
it's a short Vector in in a fake lattice
um which is this larger space that's
like orthogonal to this S1 S2 S3 instead
of eight
okay and the takeaway for this is uh
this generalize the attack on uh we can
generalize the attack on the scheme to
rule out
basically if you give out constant
manage such short vectors and you sample
a according to to such restriction it
wouldn't work you would be able to
follow the same Tech as in our paper uh
and uh so the probably the question is
okay what if I I just modified a like
even further uh give out more short
vectors uh the thing is in our paper uh
the exact attack by no works but our
intuition is that uh it might not work
in any case because intuitively does the
the verification procedure does not
force you to produce new vectors uh
different vectors in in
the lattice and uh and but nevertheless
that is based the public key Quantum
money remains largely open
uh because this is just one specific
approach where you simply apply this
says hash function it's intuitively very
easy but it might just not work but
there are other ways for example if you
have
um I owe from lattice then you have
public key on money from like lettuce
um okay and uh let's go into the second
part
uh which is a new framework for building
Quantum money
uh so uh so as I mentioned probably the
these existing public verifications they
they uh they have some similar ideas is
that uh they they because they try to
hide a classical Secret in inside the
public key about the money States and
they're usually they're what they do to
the monasteries testing something in a
computational basis and checking
something in the headmere basis try to
make sure of the structure of the state
um but what what if we we don't follow
this uh approach uh so this is something
we call Quantum lightning from workable
environment
uh let's consider a big set x uh it's
divided into many equivalence class or
say orbits this is called o
and there's some mapping function called
I we call invariant that Maps the set x
to the set y okay and it has the
property that for for
uh the elements in the same orbit or
subset o they are all mapped to the same
Y when you apply the function so this
function is like a function on the
orbits O So elements inside the same oh
they would always be mapped up to the
same y
uh and um
on that hand there is also a bunch of
other operations we you can understand
them as some sort of permutations that
allows you to go from one element in
in a subset or in orbit to another
element in the same orbit
okay um
so these and these operations only allow
you to go from elements inside the same
orbit and not not going to some other
some other different subset
and now how do we build our money uh
money skin is that okay uh very
similarly we still start with a uniform
superposition over all the elements
inside the big set X and then we apply
the invariant function coherently into
additional register and measure to get
uh get an outcome y
and now I I just use this Quantum part
the pre-image part as my column State
and the measurement outcome y as my
serial number
um
and how do I do verification because due
to limitation of time I won't go into
details but what you can do is that you
first check uh if there's money State uh
maps to if this image power maps to Y uh
to the serial number as it claims and
you try to do a projection onto the
orbit onto the equal superposition of
elements and orbit that corresponds to Y
and this you can do efficiently using
these permutations and get uh and this
is this is correctness is guaranteed by
by the properties of search permutations
over the over the orbits
um
and so how do we show security for such
a scheme I will also just go through
them briefly we need to uh majorly we
need two assumptions the first is called
path finding problem is that given two
elements uh two random elements inside
the set
and it's hard to find a sequence of
operations that goes from one to the
other
and uh so this is a very intuitive
classical analog is discrete log it's
basically I just give you group elements
and you find me the exponents that go
from one element to the other this is
for uniformly random X1 X2 yes
yeah so if the adverse we can choose
that for for himself that that might be
easy for him because he might just
figure out that sequence of operations
on its own because he prepare those so
that your question directly corresponds
to our second assumption is that okay if
I have some uh this is what we call
knowledge of past assumptions if we have
some
unitary algorithm that is all unitary
all the way until uh the last operation
where it measures it's output register
if it outputs two elements
then there is an efficient extractor
that outputs a pass in terms of that can
be efficiently expressed in terms of
these permutations between these
elements
and
and that is uh that uh that also has a
classical analog which is called
knowledge of exponent it says if a
reversible algorithm outputs to group
element it must know the exponent
and this this uh assumptions is a bit of
a leap of phase as you can probably see
so basically I say if the adversary can
output two elements on its own then it
must know the path between them
um okay uh and I I don't have time to go
into the instantiations uh but if you're
interested we can discuss offline so
basically we can we can show that as we
said this is a very general framework
and you know what are the orbits what
are the the environments but we can do
uh do them with something concrete and
one the first thing uh First
Construction is from isogi and also uh
as well as uh abstraction of isogeneous
cryptography group actions and the
second uh is called uh is a non-standard
type of functional encryption we call
re-randomizable function encryption
which also has some other properties and
uh
okay here's some open problems as I
mentioned for the lattice space Quantum
money so there may be weird parameter
regimes where you can find weird a uh
that this is hard but decision.lw is
easy that might allow you to do this
exact uh safe-based uh Quantum money
scheme
um and also of course the it's largely
open what other things you can do from
lattices and for this environmental
money there are also lots of things to
do uh so I think uh for for our our
instantiations there are still some gaps
between
the existing uh
properties we have with this specific
schemes to to the uh to the properties
we actually need for for the invariant
quantum money to work and of course we
still have these strong knowledge
assumptions maybe we can remove them and
prove the security from other some other
point of view and or you can probably
just prove those assumptions to be true
or false even in Oracle models
um yeah I think that's uh basically
everything
[Applause]
so maybe a little bit orthogonal so what
you talked about but I was wondering if
you have any thoughts on like Quantum
money is an assumption in and of itself
like private keep lots of money for
instance how does it relate to any of
the stuff people talked about today yeah
I think as far as I know there's no
implications in any directions or no
separations in any direction you mean
like uh implications or separations to
like classical Primitives uh like pke or
Quantum commitments right like like we
don't know anything right about whether
they imply Quantum money or vice versa
separated right I do think there's some
relation to one-way State generator I
think probably keep on the money
really great
right for a particular notion of it
right but yeah
very generic notion of like trying to
keep wants some money where like you
sample the secret key together with the
state like even that we don't know like
whether that relates to what my state
generators I think but the notion that's
related is like if you have a key and
you can from the key just like construct
the state then it has that same like
syntax of like classical string to
Quantum state right and that also that
has to be one way but like
just wondering if you have any like
quantum
like private key point of money or even
like Quantum lightning like I don't see
any of it's yeah
I don't know I yeah I haven't thought
about that too much it feels like
synthetically they don't
then there might be some relations
yeah but yeah I think your question is
like to other Quantum Primitives
relation right but I guess it doesn't
imply the version that is known to imply
one of my state generators right like a
generic Quantum lightning
in general yeah
it has to follow like a specific format
um
security
all right the second construction it's
for lighting
yes
right and and right the letters can
is 13 months yeah it should be easier
than possible right all right
yeah just uh
give up right if you try to also console
of money maybe can you can construct
this this big assumption
any uh for the lattice I mean this
doesn't also doesn't work for line if
you generate this state honestly
absolutely
right right but if you put the concept
of money
simpler way before with
us I think likely yes uh yeah but but we
presented this this framework just uh uh
because you know it can be a Quantum
money State uh it can be a common skin
you can do this procedure by from an
honest party uh
the thing that I uh at least for current
proof I don't think it's easier
um if it's money so it's basically the
the same proof on
so like empirically like line seems to
be like not actually that much harder to
construct than money oh that's yeah I
mean that's not I don't think that's
true but it's just that under this
specific framework
right uh
yeah maybe maybe there's something you
can show some sort of variant of the
index eraser problem
um yeah maybe in that case I think you
can
um
and if you turn this into a corner money
scheme where the state is only generated
that maybe yeah
maybe doable maybe that that that's one
take but for our current proof approach
I I think
on the money like uh and someone might
think it's literally the same here under
this framework
uh yeah I think we we sort of tried uh
uh which is basically what I said there
is another way to to view the harness of
forgering for making forgeries on the
monastery which is some sort of index
eraser problem but
we don't have any idea how to show that
[Applause]